Now we need to change the behavior of
our edit text preference appropriately.
What we'd like to do is
disable the okay, or
positive button,
until the user's typed enough text.
The first part of this is easy.
We'll override the show dialogue method
which is called the show the dialogue.
After the superclass is called,
the dialog should be present, so
we can safely fetch the edit text
view by calling get EditText.
We'll use a special callback of
EditText called an EditTextListener.
We'll add an EditTextListener
which will get
called when the user changes the text.
We'll only utilize the after
text change callback.
Now there is a tricky part.
We'd like to get the alert dialog that
is used by our edit text preference.
But, there's no supported
way to get at it.
We know it has to be there, because the
dialogue preference provides an alert
dialogue builder to
customize the dialogue.
Let's take a quick look at
the Androids source that implements
dialogue preference.
First of all,
let's grab a Chrome extension.
This extension not only makes it
easy to search the Android SDK, but
it also adds an Android View Source
link to developer.android.com.
So now we can just type AD to search for
edit text preference.
And when we see DialogPreference
we also get a link to its source.
As you can see, there's
an internal member called Mdialog.
This is what is returned in Get Dialog.
But where is it created?
As we can see, it's created for
our builder as we expected.
So at least in current
versions of Android.
We can expect this to
be an alert dialog.
Great.
But just in case this changes in
the future, we'll protect the code.
We'll use the instance of
operator to verify that
the dialog return using Get Dialog
is an alert dialog as expected.
If so, we can call dialog.get
button AlertDialog.button_positive
to get the button we need to enable and
disable.